careers in science technology
engineering and math are all about so
today I am healed if doctor and
Jefferson an assistant professor of
geology at Kent State University in Ohio
to talk about what she does her job and
why what she does rocks you see what I
did there hi I'm hi it's great to have
you on thank you so much for joining us
oh it's an honor so could you tell us a
little bit about what your job is right
now so as you said I'm an assistant
professor I'm in a geology department so
my job consists of teaching college
students about geology but more
specifically about water because the
type of science that I'm really
interested in is the science of water
flowing in rivers and water flowing
under the ground and I also do research
on those topics that's awesome so what
is that moment that you really do on a
daily basis like what is your job look
um well technically my job is half
teaching and half research but in
reality there's not a single pattern to
my day so it's more of these things are
supposed to balance out over the course
of a week or over the course of a month
or over the course of a few months so
teaching can be both in the classroom so
right now I'm teaching a whole class on
rivers but it can also be working with
undergraduate students and graduate
students on research projects that
they're interested in and then my
research can be working with the
students and it can be doing things on
my own and research entails everything
from going out in the field so out to a
stream and making measurements taking
samples bringing them back to the lab
analyzing data and maps on a computer
and then writing it all up and
explaining what's going on cool so what
is it like to teach college students
what do you have to do when you prepare
to teach a course on rivers for example
um well what
the things that's probably really
different from elementary middle school
in high school teaching is that well
sometimes there's a textbook we can use
there's really very little prepared
materials or even very much guidance in
terms of what has to happen in the
course so if I'm teaching a class on
rivers my first job is to figure out
what topics I think are important to
include in that course so for instance I
think floods are really exciting so I am
going to make sure that there's a
section in the course on what happens to
reverse during floods and how do they
change because of floods and then once
I've kind of started to think through
the topics and I have to go find a book
that has hopefully most of those topics
in it and is written at a level that's
appropriate for the students and then um
and then I have to write the whole
course from scratch so I have to figure
out what order i'm going to put the
topics in how much detail i'm going to
cover each one what assignments i'm
going to put with each topic am i going
to go for readings that are not just in
the book that are maybe on the web or in
a journal article and then the most fun
part about teaching about rivers for
instance is that I get it takes students
outside the classroom to local streams
and rivers and get them to actually make
measurements and explore processes on
their own yeah that's really fun so do
they do the students in your classes
help you with your research a little bit
um not very often in the formal class
work but sometimes they'll help me see a
feature or a process in a different way
or they'll ask me a question that gets
me thinking about what's going on or
sometimes they can collect really very
preliminary data that we can then use to
guide future research efforts so for
example a couple weeks ago I took my
class out to a stream that had been
restored or basically reconstructed over
the summer and we'd worked on it for
research prior to that reconstruction
and so my class was out there afterwards
and it was very different and they made
some measurements about the shape of the
channel in various places along the
rican
good stream well that data will then
guide my graduate student who's working
on that stream in terms of thinking
about how he wants to collect 80 there
and the sorts of measurements he's going
to make in which places in the street
that's really cool so you said that this
measurement that you guys did in a
reconstructed stream is going to help
your graduate student what kind of
projects are you currently doing in your
research in terms of Lee what your bad
student is doing eating um so there's
there's kind of three things that I'm
broadly interested in and then within
those three big themes I'm sort of have
a couple of projects that have much more
narrow focus so what fraud Lee what I'm
interested in is how water moves in
rivers and under the ground what we call
ground water and I'm interested in how
rivers and groundwater shape the
landscapes how they erode things and
deposit things and really can transform
a landscape over time and then the third
thing I'm interested in is how humans
intentionally or unintentionally are
transforming landscapes and affecting
rivers and affecting groundwater and how
all those three things kind of go into a
blender and get next up um so within
those sort of broad interest I'm looking
at things and my graduate since are
looking at things like stream
restoration so the idea that we could
take rivers or streams that have had
some negative impacts because of say
cities being built around them and try
to improve their water quality or
improve the habitat but the places where
plants and animals can live in the
stream or simply reduce the flooding and
the erosion of the stream banks and
we're trying to figure out how effective
those practices really are and what
maybe we can do in the future to be
better at restoring streams another
example of a project a student is
working on is that when we build cities
on the landscape we really reduce the
amount of water that can soak into the
ground in those places because if you
spill a cup of water on a street it
doesn't go into the ground the same way
as if you spilled it in a forest and so
more water reaches the streams in city
landscapes and that causes a lot more
flooding and a lot more erosion and can
bring in a lot more
pollution so now what what city planners
and water managers and concerned
citizens are trying to do is find ways
to put more water back into the ground
through things like rain gardens and
rain barrels and you know not washing
your car on the driveway so things like
that so there's a project up in
Cleveland where Cleveland Metroparks got
money to put in a whole bunch of rain
gardens up and down a couple of streets
and so my student and I are looking at
the data collected from the storm sewers
below the streets so if it rains on the
street some of the water goes into the
storm sewer Network and then hopefully
some of it goes into the rain gardens so
we're looking at one Street where there
are no rain gardens and one Street where
there are rain gardens and trying to see
how much of an effect those rain gardens
are having on terms of the water that's
getting into the storm sewers and
ultimately down into the street so your
research could really change how people
end up behaving and how people end up
using their water that would be the
long-term big goal it certainly wouldn't
be from anyone science project or any
one researcher alone but hopefully we
can add a little bit more information
that helps people improve the way we
design cities or the way we do stream
restoration and then other scientists
can add another little bit of
information and eventually all that
would get translated into engineering
practice and urban design cool so um no
now you told me a little bit about what
you're doing with the actual research
once you're done say comparing like one
straight one street that has rain
borough barrels versus one that does not
what happens when you have the answers
to those questions and the result of
those of that research what's the
process after that um well I think
there's two answers to that one is that
we never really have the answers to the
questions usually if we have answered
one question we've created like five
more um so maybe now if we know how
effective putting 20 rain barrels on a
single Street was our question might
become okay well can we put enough rain
barrels in a whole watershed in a whole
drainage area to make
a real difference in the stream so it
becomes sort of a it's like building
something out of Legos you know once you
put one block on then you've got space
to put more on um so that's one part of
it so science never really ends the
other part is that it's from getting an
answer and and me and my student knowing
the answer doesn't change anything so
what we have to do is communicate our
science to other scientists and the way
we do that is by writing articles and
publishing them in scientific journals
and going to conferences and talking
about them but in my field we also have
to talk to people like the regulators
that are setting up the way we design
streets or the way we manage stormwater
and we have to talk to homeowners and we
have to talk to all sorts of people that
aren't just other scientists so for
example yesterday my students and I were
at a conference called the National
nonpoint source monitoring conference
which is a lot of big words but it was
basically people from all over the
country some scientists some people who
work for cities and states and some
people who work for companies we're all
very interested in figuring out how we
can have less pollution getting in to
streams and groundwater and sharing
stories about the things that they were
trying and how well they were working
and how well maybe they weren't working
maybe lessons learned one way or the
other and so talking to people and
groups like that is a great way of
making science actually translate into
action that's really cool so I actually
majan that all this does not happen for
free you don't just go out and you know
we're putting rain barrels for free so
when you get the money to do your
research and how do you get it how much
does your research costs and you know
where do you get that money and how you
go about getting the money to do your
work that is a tough question because
you're right research doesn't happen for
free and so one of the big parts of my
job is asking for money to do the
science and it turns out that i have to
ask for money and get a lot of answers
no before i get an answer yes so some of
the places that i can get money
to do my science or things like the US
National Science Foundation or the
Environmental Protection Agency but
unfortunately there's a lot more science
than needs to be done then there's money
to fund it so like I said I get no for
an answer an awful lot um you would
think with a really applied field like
stream restoration and stormwater
management that there would be more
money around but oftentimes that money
is for doing things like buying the rain
barrels and not necessarily for doing
things like figuring out how effective
the rain barrels actually are the
science end of it so sometimes I have to
sort of get creative and and like for
example this rain gardens project were
sort of doing it for free Cleveland
Metroparks got the money to do the rain
garden installations and they got it
from the Environmental Protection Agency
and we're kind of adding the science on
there and in exchange my graduate
student will get a job hopefully with
Cleveland Metroparks at least for next
summer so there's lots of little little
bits of money that might be available um
but you know it's a continual challenge
to try to get projects done and some
projects require a lot of equipment and
streams or in groundwater and those can
be expensive but even projects where not
a lot of equipments required still
requires time from people and so
supporting graduate students and
undergraduate students to do the
research is one of the things I'm always
trying to find money to do it's good to
be realistic so can you tell me what a
typical days like for you when you're
conducting research you know when you're
actually out in the field or analyzing
data what is the day like for you doing
again there's no typical day there's
sort of three types of days there's the
days entirely in front of a computer
there's the days that are mostly in the
lab and then there are the days that are
in the field and the field days are
probably the most interesting so i guess
i'll tell you about those um and i can
tell you about some of the days that i
spent the summer in that stream that was
being about
be restored and we were sorta
frantically trying to collect data about
the stream because we knew that in a
matter of days or weeks bulldozers would
arrive and start to really just not
destroy the stream but completely
recreate it um so we would go out in the
morning and in in hip waders and and we
would do things like use survey
equipment to try and get really good
measurements of the channel shape or
there was one whole day where we pounded
about inch and a half PVC pipes into the
bottom of the stream and those pipes had
holes on them in the bottom and so
they're what we call pedometers but
basically what they do is they tell us
about water that's moving from the
stream and into the stream bed and so we
pound these pipes into the ground and
then we'd wait for them to kind of
settle out and then we'd add more water
to the top of the pipe and we watch how
quickly it disappeared back out of the
pipe and that tells us how easily water
is moving into those stream bed
sediments so if it's moving quickly than
there's into it there's a good
connection between the stream and the
groundwater and if it's moving really
slowly there's not and it turns out a
lot of really cool biology and chemistry
that happen in stream beds but they
happen because of them mixing between
the surface water or the stream water
and the ground water and so if it's
really hard to get that mixing to happen
because it's like lots of really tiny
clay particles and silt particles then
you don't get as much biological
diversity in there you don't get as much
of the biogeochemical processing which
is a fancy way of saying all the
nutrients that living things need to
live there's a lot of fancy chemistry
happening in the stream bed so I'm
trying to figure out the physical
aspects of it that'll really be kind of
the big controls on biogeochemistry in
the biology that's happening there so
yeah pounding pipes and a stream beds
and pouring water into those pipes and
then making careful measurements of how
quickly things disappear and then we had
a really long fun day where we actually
turn the stream purple so
we had a dog we had to die that we
injected into the stream so basically we
had a big trash can full of very very
purple water um and and it's completely
biologically harmless but what happens
is that a lot of it just gets moved down
in the stream water itself but some of
it moves again into the bottom of the
stream and into the bed of the stream
where all the cool biology and
biogeochemistry is happening and that
when it's moving through the stream bed
it's moving much more slowly and biology
is happening down there and this die is
super cool because when it is
metabolized basically when microbes use
it it goes from being a purple dye to
being a pink dye and so we can actually
take bottles of water in various places
in the street and at various times when
we're adding the purple dye and we can
take them back to the lab and we can
actually measure how much purple dye is
in that water and how much pink dye is
in that water and so we can measure from
that we can sort of take it back to our
computer then this is multi-day process
take it back to our computer and figure
out how much exchange there is between
the stream bed in the stream water and
how much metabolic activity or how much
biology is really going on in the stream
bed so that was a super fun day
scientifically there was lots of energy
going into hauling big tubs of water
around and getting things set up and
then once we got the experiment going i
had five four helpers sitting in various
places along the stream was basically
reading a book most the time but every
20 minutes or so grabbing a bottle of
water from the stream and saving it for
laboratory use later but the net result
is that you really did turn a stream
purple for science we really did turn a
stream purple for science and it was it
was pretty brutal this is in a city park
and we tried to get going early in the
morning but it was still pretty purple
by the time evening rolled around and it
was a nice
summer day and there was lots of all
fields and we definitely had some people
wander by and one of the my assistants
said these two women were talking to
each other and I said the stream looks
really weird today I wonder what's going
on so usually if I hear a comment like
that I try and give people sort of a
quick explanation of the science we're
doing but I wasn't a way as possible the
kids were fascinated by the purple
stream so that was really fun but we
cool so can you tell me you know it
sounds like you have a really awesome
job you get to turn streams purple for
science um but you also get to do a lot
of teaching and stuff how did you get to
where you are now like how did you get
to your current job you know where did
you start what were your prophecies that
you know mujo develop your career the
weighted um so actually I would credit a
lot of my start and science to science
fairs because i started doing science
fair projects in fifth grade like many
kids do but i kept on doing them through
metal school in high school and in that
process I discovered that I really liked
rivers um so my first science fair
project was on dish washing and the
chemistry of dishwashing and not taught
me two things I didn't like dishwashing
and I was not that into chemistry you
had to be taught that you didn't enjoy
dishwasher I think it was my mom's
excuse to get me to do um and then I did
one on snow which was pretty cool and
then I started working on rocks and
rocks were pretty they were even cooler
than snow but you know they don't really
change very fast and I grew up in the
middle of North America where the rocks
are really old they don't even have very
exciting fossils and them but I also
grew up right on the Mississippi River
and I grew up in a town on the
Mississippi River during some big floods
and so one year when I was trying to
figure out what I was going to do with
rocks for a science fair project these
big floods were going on and so we
couldn't get
the rocks we wanted to get to on the
banks of the river so I ended up working
on the river itself instead and and then
I was basically [ __ ] because um here
was something that was changing all the
time it was really important to my
community you know people lots of people
would like to go out and fish and boat
on the river but also there was a lot of
our economy was tied to the river and so
these floods were affecting people and
and the sediment that was moving through
the river was changing where the fishing
holes were how easily the boats could
move up and down river and it was just
compared to the rocks that were sitting
there and not really changing for
hundreds of millions of years the river
was super exciting um and so I started
doing fines for projects on Mississippi
River and I actually got to go to ICF
the International Science and
Engineering Fair for three years in high
school when I was a sophomore junior and
senior and I got to tell people about
the science I was doing on the
Mississippi and and to share that
enthusiasm and to get other students and
adult scientist who ask me questions and
say that what I was doing was
interesting was a really positive
reinforcement it kind of made the time
worth it plus I got to go to cities all
over the country and even all over the
world to do this and I got to meet lots
of other geeky but wonderful friendly
people kids my age you know that we're
also doing projects on science that
interested them and so knowing that I
wasn't the only person out there who is
interested in science was just a huge
motivator it's like I found my community
through science fairs and so I went off
to college to Johns Hopkins and I knew
that I wanted to do something with water
and so I majored in geology and then I
went and I got a master's degree in
water resources science from the
University of Minnesota and and then
I got a PhD in geology from Oregon State
and I spent one year after my PhD doing
research in a position that's called a
postdoc which is sort of a temporary
position and then I was hired to my
first professor job and I've been a
professor now for about seven years so
that was sort of the path that I took
that's really cool so you come into this
because of a a love of reverse and of
science and stuff so um but really do
you like what it was one of the things
that you really didn't love without your
dog I really like being able to find
answers to questions and be the first
person to know something um whether it's
just being the first person to know like
how easily water moves through that
particular piece of the stream bed or
whether it's being the first person to
kind of connect all those pieces of data
and say look this is how stream
restoration affects the way water moves
the stream bed so maybe we should think
about this um so being the first person
to see the data and kind of put the
puzzle pieces together and make sense of
things it's really exciting and as
someone who's a professor who has a PhD
I get to choose what questions I spend
my time collecting data for and so um so
I can go down routes that are
interesting to me and they're not even
necessarily things that I would have
thought five or ten years ago I would be
working on so when I was a PhD student I
worked in beautiful mountain wilderness
areas and I didn't work on streams that
were really tangibly affected by humans
in any way and then I moved to North
Carolina and I started looking around
this big city i was living in and i
realized that most people didn't get to
experience rivers in wilderness areas
most people were seeing a creek flowing
through their housing development or
maybe they weren't seeing a creek at all
because i've been put in a pipe
underground and so i started working and
more urban and human affected systems
but that was a decision that i got to
make i started to say hey you know what
this is an important question i think i
could
some of the skills that I have and start
to ask some more questions about it and
let me and then my whole research has
kind of gone that way so being the first
person to discover something and being
able to choose what questions I get to
ask is probably the most fun and
exciting part of the job for me well
that's really quote means that you can
really pursue questions that are very
important to you but also very important
to people like how we deal with our
water how we see our water what we do
with it right that sort of thing so um
we've talked about what you love about
your job and it's really really cool
what's the most frustrating is there
something really frustrating but I
you're done um there's there's two
things the first is that yes I get to
choose my own questions um but I can't
always get the money to do the science
that I want to do so sometimes I will
put a lot of myself a lot of my time a
lot of my energy a lot of my heart into
a proposal and not get funded and then I
kind of have to regroup and try a
different angle or sometimes you know
kind of give up on that entirely at
least for a while and go off into
something else so that's really hard cuz
you get really invested in the questions
you want to ask and you can I always do
them um the other part is that there's
science never sleeps and neither just
teaching and so everything is kind of
constantly going and so sometimes it
just feels like there's too many balls
in the air or just too much going on to
really keep up with um and so trying to
figure out how to manage my time
efficiently but also how to say no when
I need to say no have been some of the
bigger challenges that I've been dealing
with and will continue to deal with
indefinitely but it does sound like it's
it's pretty well worth it that you get
to do all the science that's important
to you if you get the funding to do it
anyway friends ya know I love my job
it's the perfect job for me awesome so
do you have any advice for people who
might be interested in doing what you do
for lit yeah first of all make sure it's
what you want to do so
best way to find that out is to get some
experience whether that's doing a
science fair project as a middle school
or high school or getting an internship
when you're in college or even in high
school so trying to figure out whether
it's really what fits you and then um in
in all of the sciences you need to be
comfortable with math um and with and in
my field you need to also be comfortable
with chemistry and physics so even
though I know I want to focus on rivers
and I've known I wanted to focus on
rivers since I was in ninth grade I had
to take a lot of math and a lot of
chemistry in a lot of physics and some
biology along the way as sort of the
complementary skills to the ones that I
was really trying to build so i would
say um you know not shying away from
things even if they're hard at first I
used to think that I really didn't like
math and then eventually I realized you
know what if I just work at it hard
enough I will get it and and once I
could see how it applied to the saints
that was interested in I just gained a
lot more comfort and confidence with it
so not giving up as you go along so
getting that all the sciences together
and seeing how they fit together and
then just persistence awesome it's true
the more you practice you know math
chemistry stuff like that the more you
see how it applies to what you want to
do and the easier it gets because it
gets more interesting okay so the last
question I have for you you have died a
stream purple for science is that the
weirdest thing you have done for science
what's the weirdest thing that you have
done in the name of science um well you
Dinah stirring purple was pretty weird
um it's funny because I just think of
like this is what I do for science this
is what I do for my job and so I stopped
things that other people would probably
say we're really weird I don't think of
as weird anymore um but one thing that
sort of continually cracks me up is when
I go to the grocery store to get my
family's groceries but I also do things
like by fifty aluminum pie pans so that
I can bring them to my lab and take
cores of soil and open them up
dry them up on the pie pans or like
searching and searching and searching
for exactly the right size Tupperware
container to store a syringe in so it's
like under the perfect amount of water
yeah my shopping carts are sometimes
very random but um last year total it
was a great thing for syringes pepper
where is Ray yes it's a jelly roll pan
turned out to be just what I needed um
but last year there was a space of about
a week where I was ordering stuff for my
lab to use as internal lab standards so
so samples that will measure over and
over and over again and we'll compare
other results too and so I measure water
and I needed water from a really hot
place and from a really cold place um so
I ended up buying two cases of bottled
water one from a high elevation site in
Colorado and one from Hawaii so I had to
basically justify spending forty dollars
on fancy bottles of water from that you
can't drink yeah that I that I'm
actually never tasted oh and then once
those bottles of water arrived I had to
I can just store them in plastic bottles
because they might evaporate and that
would throw off what I'm trying to
measure and so I needed really good
containers to pour all the bottles of
water into and it turns out that the
type of containers I needed were beer
kegs so in the space of a week I ordered
forty dollars worth of bottled water and
three beer kegs so did you did you
justify beer kegs work for science they
were for sign when we had to specially
modify them so that we could do exactly
what we wanted to do with them that's
removing okay so thank you so much for
participating in this Google hangout I'm
very excited to be able to post this on
Eureka lab thank you so much for your
time and I hope that you inspire lots of
people to go a look at their livers in a
new way thanks for having me